hi everyone my name is urban fossil and
today i'm going to talk about our recent
work ensembles in the robust sparse
model discovery in the low data high
noise limit with active learning and
control this is joint work with nathan
kutz bing branton and steve brunton and
you can find our preprint on the archive
and the code is already implemented in
the latest version of the pi's in the
package all right so easing is an
extension of the cindy algorithm that
tries to robustify
the model discovery especially in the
low data and high noise limit
and in this short video today i will
first review the cindy algorithm and
then talk about our extension and show
some first results
all right so most of you that follow
steve's youtube channel might be
familiar with the cindy algorithm or the
sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics so the cindy algorithm is a
model discovery algorithm that tries to
identify
models that best fit
non-linear dynamics
purely from data so for example in the
case of the lorenz system we start with
collecting data so we collect a time
series of data
we use this then to compute the time
derivatives
and we then also compute a large library
of candidate non-linear
functions so
functions that we believe could describe
our unknown dynamics of interest
and then after computing these
derivatives time derivatives and this
large library of candidate nonlinear
functions
we solve a sparse regression
problem to find the fewest active terms
in our dynamics and we can do this for
example by using a sequentially
threshold at least squares algorithm
where we
sequentially solve a least squares
problem and then threshold coefficients
that are below a certain sparsification
parameter that we defined beforehand
all right so this is uh cindy now the
challenge with uh sin you're not just
with cindy but with all model uh
discovery uh methods is that
they tend to be very sensitive to noise
and especially in the low data limit so
it's very difficult to find accurate
sparse models if our data is highly
noise corrupted and if we only have very
little data
then a second
when we use cindy we identify a
deterministic model and oftentimes we're
interested in the uncertainty or an
estimate of the uncertainty of our model
coefficients
so what we would like to have is a cindy
algorithm that is
more noise robust
that also
generates or identifies a probabilistic
model and in this direction there are
some recent extensions of cindy that
deal with this so for example in terms
of robustifying cindy the recent
integral formulation or also ensembling
methods were introduced and in terms of
uncertainty uh
some by asian sparse identification
methods were recently introduced
and in our work with e-cindy we unify
and extend
these methods so we use ensembling to uh
robustify cindy and we exploit the
ensemble statistics to produce or
identify probabilistic models
all right now so what do i mean with
ensembling
so instead of using our data and
building or identifying a single cindy
model we can take bootstraps of our time
derivative matrix and
library matrix
and
take these bootstraps and build an
ensemble so multiple cindy models and
with bootstrapping we mean random
sampling with a replacement and apply to
cindy where we have
m samples in time that represent our m
time steps that we measure we would
sample m new rows with replacement from
this original
data and then generate
n bootstraps and identify n cindy models
in the ensemble so instead of just
identifying a single cindy model we
take n bootstraps of our data we build n
cindy models and then we can basically
exploit the ensemble statistics to
find coefficients that are unlikely to
appear in our dynamics we cut them off
and then we aggregate a final e-cindy
model so for example we could then take
the mean or the median of our identified
modal coefficients in the ensemble to
find a final
cindy model or e-cindy model that best
describes our unknown dynamics
and what is really nice about this
method is that we get uncertainty in the
coefficient so we don't just get a
single model but we can
get
model coefficient distributions and also
we get inclusion uh probabilities of our
coefficients so probabilities of how
likely will a certain coefficient appear
in
our
models of the ensembles in the ensemble
of our identified cindy models and what
we can do with this is then to run
ensemble forecasts that provide
confidence intervals of our forecasts so
our e-cindy method connects to sparse
patient interference as we identify
probabilistic models
and the great advantage
of our e-cindy method is that it's
extremely computationally efficient so
compared to for example a markov chain
monte carlo based methods that can
easily take several hours to identify a
cindy model
our
e-cindy
method can identify
probabilistic models within seconds
all right so with e-cindy we can
robustify the cindy algorithms and
identify um probabilistic models that
can be used for ensemble or
probabilistic forecasting
now
in our paper we
apply uh this new e-cindy method to a
range of challenging problems so for
example the first one is where uh we try
to discover an ode uh only based on 21
experimental data points so we take
links in here pelts measurements that
were
measured between 1900 and 1920
and with e-cindy
we are able to identify the
volterra dynamics with only these 21
experimental uh data points so we can
identify
uh models in the very low data limit
then we also apply our e-cinema method
to discover pds and here we show that we
can robustify
the pde model discovery by using uh
ensembl cindy so we show this on a range
of pde data sets and in our paper we
show that by using ensembling our method
only breaks down with twice as much
noise as if we wouldn't use ensembling
so we can clearly show that by using
ensembling we can robustify
the model discovery of pdes
all right
then what is also really interesting and
what we show in our paper is that we can
also exploit the ensemble statistics
for active learning so
often times are actually always it is a
very time consuming and expensive to run
experiments or run simulations
so
we are interested in efficient
exploration so basically trying to
only run experiments or simulation that
maximally inform our model discovery so
we don't want to randomly perform a set
of experiments or simulation but we want
to
efficiently explore our future space to
only run experiments that
maximally inform our model discovery so
that really help us to identify accurate
and sparse models and to do this we can
use e-cindy so we can exploit the
ensemble statistics to find and explore
high uncertainty regions in the future
space so instead of just running a
random set of experiments and building a
single cindy or e-cindy model we can
iteratively identify e-cindy models to
improve the data efficiency of the model
discovery and what i mean with this is
so for example we could start with only
running a very small set of experiments
or simulations and then use this small
data set to build a first e-cindy model
and then we use this e-cindy model to
find out where we have the highest
uncertainty in our future space and we
can do this for example by saying if we
take again the lorenz system dynamics we
use our cindy models and we run a set of
ensemble forecasts starting from
different initial conditions
and then we compute the ensemble of
forecast variance
and
find
the initial condition or the region in
our future space with the highest
uncertainty and then we only sample the
true dynamics at this exact initial
condition so we only
run an experiment that maximally informs
our model discovery
and we show that by using e-cindy for
active learning we can reduce the
variance of our identified model
coefficients and we can improve the data
efficiency of the model discovery uh
algorithm so we can basically find
more accurate models with
less training data or with running less
experiments
all right then the last
example that we show in our paper is
where we apply e-cindy to identify
models that also have external inputs or
control inputs and these models can for
example be used in a model predictive
control framework and in the paper we
show that by using ensembl cindy we can
get more accurate controllers with less
training data
so basically we can get
better control
faster so we don't need to train our
models that long but we can get
very quickly very accurate controllers
by using ecindi
all right so
to summarize easy improves the
robustness and accuracy of cindy
especially in the high noise and low
data limit
easily produces probabilistic models in
seconds
compared to existing variation methods
that can take several hours
and finally we can also exploit the
ensemble statistics to uh
for active learning and for improved
more accurate control
all right so
again you can find our preprint on the
archive and the code implemented in the
latest
version of the piscindi package
thanks for listening